so we have four graphs here and then
four function definitions and what i
want you to do is pause this video and
think about which of these graphs map up
to which of these function definitions
so i'm assuming you've given a go at it
let's go through each of these and think
about what their graphs would look like
so one thing that i like to do because
it's just a simple thing to do is just
think about what happens when x is equal
to 0 especially when x is in an exponent
like this you would have let me just
write this down y of 0
is going to be equal to two minus one
third to the zero power that's equal to
two minus one one third to the zero is
one which is equal to one
so in which of these graphs it when x is
equal to zero do we have y equaling 1.
here x equals 0 y equals negative 1.
here x equals 0 y equals negative 1. it
looks like negative 1. here x equals 0 y
looks like 1. so this is a candidate
here when x is equal to 0 y also looks
like 1. so these last two seem like a
candidate for this for this function
definition right over here
now let's think about the behavior of
this function let's think about what
happens when x approaches a very very
large number so when x approaches a very
large number
so let's just imagine let's just imagine
y of
y of a thousand
and a thousand really isn't that large
of a number but let's just that's going
to be two minus one third
to the thousand power
well a thousand to the a third to the
thousand power that's going to be very
very very small number we're multiplying
a third times a third or third you're
taking a thousand one-thirds and
multiplying them together so you're
gonna get a number very very close to
zero so let me write this down this this
part right over here is going to be
close to zero
close
to zero another way to think about it is
x increase as x increases this part
approaches zero so this is very close to
zero this thing y of a thousand y of
one thousand will be close
to
two or another way of thinking about it
as x gets larger and larger and larger
this part is going to get closer and
closer and closer to zero so you're
gonna have two minus something that's
closer and closer and closer to zero so
as x gets larger y is going to approach
two
so which of these two have that behavior
what's clearly this one on the right as
x gets larger and larger and larger we
see that y is getting closer and closer
and closer and closer to
two so this one right over here we could
say is y is equal to 2 minus
1 3
to the
x power we could also think about its
behavior as x gets smaller as x gets
more and more and more negative so 1 3
to a very negative number right over
here that's the same thing as
pause us as 3 to a very positive value
so as x gets more and more and more
negative this will be essentially three
to a posi a more and more positive value
and so and you're subtracting it from 2
so y is going to become more and more
and more negative so we see that as x
becomes more and more negative y becomes
more and more negative so this once
again is consistent
now let's think about this
this function right over here
so here we see y is equal to one half to
the x
minus two
so
we could first of all just think about
what y of zero is
y of zero is going to be one half
to the 0 power minus 2 which is equal to
1 minus 2 which is equal to negative 1.
so both of these would be candidates for
this function right over here when x is
equal to zero y is negative one when x
is equal to zero y is negative one
but now let's think about the behavior
of this function as x becomes larger and
larger and larger values what is y going
to approach
well just like we saw over here you have
a fraction you have one half being
raised to larger and larger and larger
values so let's think about this as this
gets raised to larger and larger values
this part is going to approach zero
one-half times one-half times one-half
times one-half that's going to approach
zero fairly fairly quickly and so as
this approaches zero y is going to
approach negative two
so
as x gets larger and larger and larger
one-half to the x approaches zero and so
y is going to be is going to be is going
to be just it's going to approach
negative two from above so let's see
where we see that well that looks like
this one right over here once again we
said these are our two candidates when y
is zero or when x is 0 y is negative 1.
and here we see as x gets larger and
larger and larger y is approaching
negative 2 because this part is becoming
smaller and smaller and smaller values
so this one is that one
right over there and you could also
think about its behavior as x becomes
more and more negative as x becomes more
and more negative that's like raising pi
that's like raising 2 to a positive
value so 2 to a positive value you see
that as x becomes more negative y
becomes larger and larger and larger
all right got 2 left y equals 2 to the x
well this might be the simplest of all
y equaling 2 to the x power well when x
is equal to zero y should be equal to
one and we see that's this graph right
over here and this is pretty just this
is kind of your most basic type of
exponential function as x increases y
increases this is kind of your classic
exponential graph shape and as x
approaches more and more negative values
as x approaches large or more and more
negative values this is to raising two
to a very large negative value so
imagine as when x is imagine y of
y of even negative 10 this isn't even
that negative that's going to be 2 to
the negative 10 power which is the same
thing as one-half
to the 10th power
so as y as x becomes more and more and
more negative this expression is going
to get closer and closer and closer to
zero so this one is clearly that one
and then finally just deductive
reasoning you could say that this
function is represented by that graph
but let's reason through a little bit
and this is where order of operations
really matters when you see negative 3
to the x it might be a little confusing
you're like is it negative is it the
whole negative 3 to the x power or is it
negative 3 to the x and here we just
have to remind ourselves order of
operations exponentials are are are the
top priority right after parentheses and
so you would actually do your
exponential first you take 3 to the x
it's going to be the negative of that so
it's essentially going to be it's going
to be your classic exponential function
but because of this negative you're
going to flip it over the x-axis and
that's what this has right over here as
x gets larger and larger and larger 3 to
the x is going to become a much larger
and larger value but then we're taking
the negative of it so y is going to
become smaller and smaller and smaller
likewise as x is more and more and more
negative three to the x is going to
approach zero and when x is equal to
zero three to the zero is one but you
have a negative out front we see y is
negative 1. so this is y is equal to
negative 3
to the x power